I'm envisioning a future where we've got
personal assistance that we've paid for
who basically help us live a life in the
way that we want to that I approach
these problems in a way that people
around me don't approach them yes at
trees we're building a point-of-sale
environment so that we can optimize the
sales experience for dispensaries
thinking about the problems that these
vendors have and how to make it better
for them get product we need to sell
product we need to track product we need
to be compliant so that the state and
the government doesn't do anything
harmful to us if I get lost I might go
out to the beach to listening to the
waves listening to the sound what I
found is that people who want to reach
out and connect back to themselves
through music right tend to have the
most unbelievable cognitive abilities
when it comes to coding like they they
produce not only the most beautiful code
but the most effective and correct code
[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don sake on we
are still at new West Summit which is
the world's leading cannabis tech
conference and we are now sitting down
with will Greene what's up man
appreciate you coming on will and I have
had some great conversations just in the
last couple s than an hour of knowing
each other so I'm really excited to
unpack with you will it has an
electrical engineering computer science
background from Rice he has then went on
to work with as a VP of engineering at
revel and now as the CTO of trees and so
we will unpack more about the kind of
like how to how to manage assets in a
retail environment and optimize that
process we'll talk about that but we
want to talk about what we were
initially talking about for the last
like 20 minutes which was a lot about
meaning and finding fulfillment in life
and doing what you love every single day
and I want you to just you know talk
about that because you were just really
on fire about it I don't know if I can
repeat that performance where's the
hitch-hiker guide quote I need to do
that now
they you know what I was telling you
earlier really is that I I want to wake
up in the morning and I want to be able
to get out of bed and then go do
something that is actually my goal right
something that I wanted to do something
that I wake up and I'm like yes I'm
doing this I'm charging off right so
instead of just getting out of bed and
brushing my teeth and again going off
and kind of doing a routine I literally
don't wake up and do the same thing
twice ever like I do wake up and do like
the routine things the brushing of the
teeth but when I wake up I go to work
and it's always a new challenge like
every single day at work is a new
challenge and so for me you know what I
was characterizing earlier is that I
will lie you know after after the day of
work right and and I tend to work on a
lot of hours just because the hours just
they just disappear right it's not I'm
sitting there at work and I'm looking at
my watch it's usually I look at my watch
and I'm like whoa what happened it's
eight or ten o'clock at night right so
it's just like literally the time just
disappears I have like this great sense
of accomplishment every single day I
feel like I've done significant things
and and you know and not just impacting
myself but impacting like the people I
work with impacting the people that I'm
building things for right so at the
simplest level at trees we're building a
point-of-sale environment so that we can
optimize the sales experience for
dispensaries right so a dispensary will
come in and they're like we have all
these things we need to do we need to
give product we need to sell product we
need to track product we need to be
compliant so that the state and the
government doesn't do anything harmful
to us right so we can stay in business
so you know trees is like trees is hyper
focused on that like my my entire day is
around kind of thinking about the
problems that these vendors have and how
to make it better for them right but the
other half of this is that every single
day I wake up and I'm like there's this
new human challenge right right before I
got here
I talked to one of the trees employees
and in he asked me a very emotional
question and it's kind of like he's like
he's like I'm a young guy and I don't
really know what to do with my life I
don't know where I'm going and
no I don't I don't know what to do and
the conversation ended up going the same
route of this one which is the get out
of bed think about something significant
anything significant it doesn't matter
what it is and if you can't identify
something significant think about things
that will help you identify something
significant right yes right you know
think about something that just strikes
your fancy like for me if I get lost I
might go out to the beach really early
in the morning yeah right because oddly
even though I'm in an industry where
it's very analytical and I do a lot of
thinking and I just do a lot of that for
some reason being the on the beach
listening to the waves listening to the
sound like maybe even going out on a
surfboard and and not necessarily like
actually surfing right because that's
like it's not about that it's about that
moment where everything is quiet and
where you just like you you reach the
inside meaning of something to yourself
you're like this matters right and then
you come out of the water or you get off
the beach or whatever it is you're doing
and you're like I have this one thing
that is like my purpose for this moment
and and so you know that's that's pretty
much my day I wake up every single day
and I just like I latch onto that thing
that makes me feel some fire and then I
go and I do it no matter what it takes I
push as hard as I can for it and then I
go home and I feel really good every
single day I love this so alright you
also made this really interesting
distinction between sort of when you're
grinding out something that's really
meaningful to you and you're hustling
that out and then that doesn't always
mean that what you're grinding or
hustling out has something to do with
the human problem the human path to
meaning and fulfillment so then you
might be thrown a curveball because then
one of the employees walks up and says
you know I'm not finding that much
meaning in my life right now that's a
really big difference from coding or
from Electrical Engineering or from
pretty much business in many ways and so
that's like okay I'm redirecting my
attention to human meaning first of all
I congratulate you because it requires
someone to be emotionally intelligent
Polymathic to be able to distinguish the
as like that's also something I can help
with and that's something that I care
about so then you go and you choose to
you know to redirect resources and
energy to help with that and then come
back and I also really liked how you
made it clear to people that it's
important to go and do something in
nature not always behind a computer
screen it just gives you a deeper
insight and even for people that love
being behind computer screens all the
time like especially children that just
are obsessed with it you know it's
almost like we haven't offered them the
tool or the resource to understand what
a tree is to its ecosystem of animals
and plants that live around it and stuff
they have to get that's some one of
those kind of basic knowledge things
that I think I forget okay enough with
that you were also venturing us into
into trees a bit and I was also making
good connection to what you were saying
earlier by kind of this hole we talk a
lot on the show about the nuance and all
the multi variability there's business
owners go through trillions of variables
and especially regarding inventory and
managing that and the design of the
location and what they do with profit
and yeah tell us about how the hell did
you manage this it's absolutely amazing
in this industry so what I discovered
when I first got here like I came from
Revell where the background was more
it's just a lot more mature in terms of
like how they do operations their
margins are so much more lean right so
they've had to mature more and here they
have the capacity to basically start
afresh from all these problems right
there's amazing culture people really
care about each other people people hug
each other like you don't see that at
you know
Nordstrom's or any of these places like
there's none of that right if they hug
each other it's because they're really
good friends as opposed to because
they've got this sense of community in
relationships and so you know what's
interesting is that the capacity for
that has made it so that the maturity of
you know operationalizing and making
your business more efficient you don't
have to focus as much early okay but
then if you want to start taking the
next step you have to think about that
you have to think about like you know
how do I manage my
boys how do I make sure they're paid the
right how do I make sure they get the
right number of hours how do I make sure
they had the right tenure right and
that's just labor management so then you
look at product right how do I get the
product in how do I make sure the
product is is not spoiling or getting
stolen or just like you know something
bad happens to whatever happens right
because even that first distinction you
made right there was between labor and
the actual product that's that's in
itself that's the human distinction and
that requires a lot of time resources
understanding all that stuff right yeah
and and and that's why to me when I look
at trees these these problems are super
complicated right I just did this pen on
technology and there's this piece of me
that was like just crying out I was like
I really want to be on the panel to
instead of just a moderator but you know
at the time I was like my job is to
connect the dots for these guys to give
these guys a chance to shine and I'll
inject a few comments here and there but
really if I take over the panel then I'm
gonna go off on this deviation of like
no one will be able to follow right
because the the complexity of trees and
what it does and kind of like all this
ecosystem management you know we can
start talking about AI but we don't talk
about AI the way we would for you know
genome detection and things like that
you know that's very deep science some
very deep mathematics but what about the
fact that you'd use AI to go out and
start predicting human behaviors right
and and and maybe somebody would come
back and say that's not as deep right
but but it kind of is by the time you've
collected all the data points and you're
like this guy shopped here at this
location at this time of the day during
this period in the month when the
weather was like this and you know
previous to that you know these three
events happen maybe as a holiday maybe
maybe there was some kind of supply
change somewhere right so and I'm just
naming like a handful of variables right
all these things he had collected up and
then they feed in let me let me give you
another like very kind of name any
example of what what a point-of-sale can
do for you so
and those who are like whoa yeah so now
as now let's talk about product okay so
check this out you come into your
dispensary okay they've got fresh fresh
flower right and they're like okay we
know that we've got connoisseurs who
shop here these are guys that are they
love their product like they and me and
they come in and they're gonna squeeze
it and feel it and they're gonna look at
it and they're gonna study it and so
there's there's actually an art to how
you put that out you don't just take it
out and put it on the counter or put it
in a jar and you know stick it on the
shelf all right that creates like a
pretty arrangement and that creates like
you know that there's an aspect of the
human side of that but on the product
side you know that if you take the
product out of its case at this hour
that it will then cause this much kind
of scent to get into the air and you can
place it in this location so that it's
the most visible right so now you're
looking at the product aspects and how
it interacts with the consumer right and
then based on that you're like okay now
I'm gonna take it to the next level
not only how am I going to understand
how to draw that human person in the
shopper I'm gonna draw the man by like
getting the visuals getting the smells
and you know offering them the
opportunity for touch right so now
they're drawn in now you're like all
right now I need to know how to manage
the inventory how do I get it into the
system the right numbers at the right
time and have it here at the right spot
so you're also making a better more
analytical human as they better
understand and are playing with and
smelling and etc I've got to tell you a
story about analytic and an AI that's
gonna scare you after this okay so very
much so right fear mongering now this
isn't this isn't this is gonna blow your
mind
this is gonna blow your mind okay all
right so so now now you've got this
thing that basically optimizes the
inventory so that it comes in and you
don't get as much waste you don't get as
much spoilage you don't even have the
product out for anything bad to happen
to it right and therefore you've reduced
all potential for loss increased your
potential for sale you've optimized
right and I'm making a pretty simple
sounding but it's like you know it
scale level that's a hard problem so
it's scale that's a tough problem to
solve okay now check this out this is
you're gonna love this so now you've got
a system that studies you as you come in
you're a shopper right you come in you
shop and it's like oh you buy this
product and then starts like analyzing
all the all the data and so it'll start
studying you right it's like you fit
into this age demographic you're this
gender you're you know your zip code is
this right all these little data points
right ok now I love this and I hate it
at the same time the random person will
come in who fits your demographic and
the engine will say sell them that
product you see where I'm going
ok so now and then and then guy and then
and then people how did you get that so
fast
if the data is anonymized it couldn't be
like oh interesting yeah so ii so that's
why it's biased but it's also that wait
let me see if i can get this so is it
right then that hmm if someone comes in
fitting my demographic and if the data
was anonymized then it would also see if
I'm buying the 10 milligram edible once
a week they would also see that they're
buying 1/8 once a week but then we're
both anonymous but we fit each other's
demographics so then the engine would
recommend one of those two things so
it'd be like this person either wants
one of those two things okay now on the
simple level that seems like it's not
that bad like most people are like oh
that's [ __ ] cool that we get to
actually recommend a good product to
this person yeah but as you a granade
this data out and you think bigger
picture right like AI and data has the
potential to just go completely wrong
yes and the most fascinating ways and
annual audit it right you'll be able to
explain exactly why it it biased you own
that thing only if the data is anonymous
because if it's if it is if we have
given permissions to give away our
privacy then it will know that it's Alan
that walked in the store
and when yeah right but you've got to
consider this too is that we're moving
in that direction of anonymized data
like that is the future right where
we're taking IDs right now when
everybody comes in but there's going to
be a short life for that there's gonna
come a period of time where people are
like why are you taking my driver's
license let me show you my driver's
license and you can hand check it and
verify it but you don't get to have my
driver's license you don't get to have
my driver's license number you don't get
to have all that PII we're not far from
that right because we're moving from a
pure personal information what's the
last I personally identifiable
information so so we've heard arguments
and this is interesting now that we're
here that we got here we've heard
arguments for complete transparency as
in what if I'm not doing anything wrong
at all
then why does it matter that I have full
complete transparency that there are
companies and government watching
because I'm not doing anything wrong
anyway so why not have full transparency
and that's kind of a little
authoritarian route like China in some
ways is taking and then there's the
other route which is if everything's
blocked chained and anonymized to the
degree of which I've already went in and
you already know you ready you you
already know who I am you never need to
check anymore but i'm anonymized so
people still can't quite know all right
I have a extremely radical viewpoint on
this so it's my opinion that you talk
about blockchain so let's talk about
instead of talking about with fancy
words let's say that we've got a record
of every single thing that you've ever
done for all time yes okay yes so what I
would like to do is I'd like to move to
a model where you have a record of all
things that Alan has done yeah not not
me for every human well every human
would have their own individual rate and
recommendation engines become
recommendations based on your one single
string your entire life line and not
this cross-pollinated thing because okay
let's take this worst case let's take
this worst case
I start collecting data about drivers
and before you know it I can prove that
this demographic of drivers will have
cannabis in their car at this time of
night on this week okay
and then I do write the string of
experiences was very interesting because
you know we we now we think a lot about
then I'm writing a lot about this right
now about time and attention in the
human race and all these other things
but one of them that's really specific
is I'm just a little bit upset that we
have yet to have made a will timeline
like from the moment will was born why
are your experiences through your life
like oh I took this photo when I was 2
and there's this home video when I'm 4
and there's the social media postings
from one I'm 14 times 16
but that's the closest we get to some
sort of a put together yeah and I would
love to see an individual string as you
were saying from birth to death let's
say of experiences that are documented
per person and then like you said the
recommendations that are made based on
their string and not allen string or
sally string and and if you think about
this in the extreme case of somebody
who's probably somewhat radical like me
right and it's it's weird to label
myself as a radical but you know like
i'm i'm not overtly radical it's just i
think that that's owned by me right that
string of myself is owned by me i think
if i just happen to have done something
that you also did i didn't have the same
reasons right and so it's like it's this
culmination of events and it's so damn
complicated that pretending like I made
the same product choice for the same
reasons as you did right there's so many
factors yeah and okay yeah it's you know
at some point you can get it right
because it's like throwing a hand
grenade
yeah right like you literally are just
sorting a hand grenade and you're like
alright I got a hand grenade I know that
with these variables that there's like
an 80% chance that it's going to be
right and you just lob it off and yeah
80% of the time you're right
something that's a hundred percent of
the time right for someone what they
want to do with their string of
experiences next I think you could not
only do I think you could but I think
like with technology and the way it's
going and I think with like all the
different pieces that we're looking
about this is where like you know this
panel eyes on it's like holy cow imagine
we sit here and start talking about like
the radical changes that we can do with
the mass amount of data collection I
could do just about myself I get my own
key to that little vault I can unlock it
then this engine goes through and looks
at and it's like ask me a few key
questions what were you thinking at this
time of your life what was going on in
your life like what was your emotional
state you know did you do this this and
this right and then all the sudden
you've got factors that cause you to be
able to understand my judgment right
then you're making a recommendation for
me based on my past and you could ask me
questions about why I woke up this
morning so you know how you're doing
this interview you're like what are you
building why not make the recommendation
what are you building and then it looks
your life and it figures it out it's a
math formula it has no bearing what you
do with your life it's like this is my
life right and then I don't have to
worry about what Allen does I like you
know I just lived my life
and I lived my life in the best possible
way and I wake up and when I get a new
recommendation it's a I want to take it
to this direction so there's enough data
about my personal life
that's siloed into my string that then
if properly computed could make a 100%
accurate recommendation for what I could
do next in order to have most meaning in
my life absolutely think about
everything that's happened in your life
think about that one moment that
something bad was going on to you like
there's you know everybody has their
moments of tragedy and when the moment
of tragedy hits other like you know
events will kind of beat in your life
you'll get a speeding ticket or you know
some some ridiculous thing will happen
right but there's like this tendency as
you're is your mental state changes as
your life changes to either like have
really good things happen or to have
really bad things and those are a result
of you know and this is this is my
radical opinion those are a result of
like all these indicators and pieces and
the machine that's in your head not some
guy came on and he's like
I can predict the product that you want
and I can kind of nudge you in that
direction yes we can influence each
other we all know that right but at the
end of the day if I put myself in a
vacuum
I could still arrive at that same
decision because I look at all the
things that are about myself and then
I'm like okay you woke up in the morning
and you didn't get enough sleep right
and you were feeling whatever you were
feeling right and so therefore you
decided to go to Starbucks and get some
coffee I'm being silly but you see where
I'm going I it's like that you're saying
this that this opinion is and maybe
instead of radicals fine but sometimes
it can have a negative connotation maybe
it can be just unusual or you can maybe
use the word Copernicus like so few
people think about it that way if my
vocabulary was that big I will tell you
this much I extend yeah yeah all I know
is at the end of the day that I approach
these problems in a way that people
around me don't approach them yes and
and sometimes I don't really understand
that sometimes I do it's like let's fix
that we can well let's let's fix that
let's blitz put together the people
around you that approach problems and
and somewhat similarly unconventional
ways yeah let's do that
man I don't that was a fascinating exit
that we took on data and privacy that
was a really good exit I like that one a
lot and I loved the string actually for
some reason I don't know why but the
string is like the spine of the central
nervous system and like it's like the
birth might be the where the tailbone
where it ends at the tailbone and then
the is the the brains and their so your
chronological experience is from birth
go up until you're 30 and then until
you're 60 and then the yeah but the Olga
feeds into the brain but at the end is
kind of the brain is the
be the compliment yeah let's let's see
if we can get more of these because you
know these metaphors give better more
relatable understandings okay and so
just to just to be clear with with data
and privacy you like the idea of that
individual experience string being only
your ownership so then if it's only your
ownership that would mean that the
Facebook Amazon etc data that you
purchase Amazon goods with the news
Facebook with that that data itself
would be blocked chained and anonymized
and then how would that how would how
would yeah and then what would the AI
engine for your personal recommendations
how would it would it would it be like
okay you've purchased the CI
recommendation engine for 250 bucks the
data is shared with nobody is that would
be how it would work
that's exactly how it would work okay
now look at the other side of the coin
so we all talked about how we're gonna
do data for the vendors and and data for
the for the growers and all that right
do they need to know that Allen bought
anything hmm
like do they need to know that they just
need to know that the product moves in
the store they need the store's profile
they need a blockchain for the store or
it doesn't even need to be a blockchain
because who cares it's a store they
don't need to know anything about the
people shop there all they need to know
is that the store has its aspects and
its characteristics then the
point-of-sale can optimize the
experience there right you can optimize
how everything flows through the shop
you can understand that you move this
kind of product and you're like okay how
do I move some different kind of product
okay if you want to if you want to
market to the people that are going to
buy a different product right and I'm
speaking in very general terms you don't
need to know any demographic information
about them you just pick that
demographic and then you attempt a
market like this is what happens anyway
right they go out and they do studies
and they're like okay 25 to 30 males
will buy this and you know in this if
code they'll buy this and this and this
right but in reality all they need to do
is is understand that you know the store
is in this location
and the store is selling these products
and these are the factors that they know
impact it right number of people that
come right and then they can start to
vary their demographics inside of there
in terms of like targeted marketing
right but but the point of this is say
like you can create a signature of the
store and the store doesn't have to have
any kind of signature that says this is
Alan at all right right and now at some
point we'll take this logical argument
to what people are trying to call
anonymized data yeah right now you're
also making it clear that there are
these sort of varying levels of of data
signatures that why would the store need
to tell the grower that who's buying it
just that it is moving is enough that it
is moving off the shelves and then the
next layer of data would be like well
does the store need to know who is it
who is buying it so that they can maybe
make personalized recommendations and
that kind of stuff there's these sort of
layers of data signatures that everybody
thinks right now that the store needs to
know so that they can action the the the
information that they have right so like
the gut reaction is I need to know that
it's these people in this location with
this particular characteristic set that
are buying the product right now and so
therefore I will market to those exact
same people in another location to bring
that location in right so that I
increase my penetration my overall
awareness but you know you don't
necessarily like it's still a shot in
the dark right and so you know I think I
think at the end of the day what I'd
like to see happen is that we pivot
things upside down what's your i want to
pivot the whole thing with you why not
so they're optimized the heck out of the
store make the store work really well
right and then fully empower the
consumer so the consumer then markets to
themselves over time right and then
basically you know create relationships
and community that will cause people to
be exposed to each other and learn about
each other and then try to explore these
new things right what's
movie everybody really likes Minority
Report all right Mike
you know what he shows up and and he's
in trouble
but it's like he walks in and everything
is directly at him right and so it's
like he's getting all the information he
needs to know to make his life choice
whatever that life choice is so I do you
want to go on a vacation do you want
this do you want this do you want this
but it's it's him right and and the
person who's like in the average
technology mindset right and by average
I mean today's men said would think hey
somebody built an engine that is
targeting demographically the reality is
is that that engine can exist for that
person and target them that way yeah
right yes we were mentioning about this
the I'm purchasing a $250 recommendation
engine that only I own that only makes
recommendations for my unique string of
experiences right now let's look at the
Amazon Marketplace right this is a good
example because like it's it's realizing
exactly what I'm telling you which is
basically if you look at the Amazon
Marketplace and you go out there right
you mean we could create Amazon
Marketplace accounts and we could go out
and make you know a canteen or whatever
right anything and you can sell it you
can make a livelihood you don't know
anything about the people that are
buying you just know raw numbers is it
selling is it not selling what's the
price point right the very basics of
economics and then you just keep on
driving it that way and then the
community is like sharing with each
other and they're influencing each other
and they're giving each other stuff and
then you as an individual you show up
and you read things right you're making
your own decisions you don't have a
recommendation engine running for you
but you're basically learning and
evolving over time and then you're
making your decision then you put on a
recommendation engine and it'll go out
and do everything you would have done
manually right it's got your whole life
story it's got everything about it goes
out collects a bunch of data and then it
gives you some information and you
wanted that that job
interesting okay well you will here's
this is this is too good to leave so
here here's I was just running a
simulation in my of what this would look
like so I have a AI engine that I
purchase only for me no one owns the
data except me the AI engine
recommendations will only stay with me
etc so then I tell the AI engine to go
and take my photos from Facebook or
Instagram or Twitter LinkedIn whatever
and then I also have it maybe parse
github for those that code my URL for
those that have a website learns learns
all about you and then it says that I
noticed that your Google Calendar has
six straight days with meetings or work
let's why don't why don't you look at
this game of volleyball and picnic
that's happening in Golden Gate Park on
Sunday at two o'clock and is something
is something like that
okay that makes sense to me basically
it's it's studying your past and it's
now looking at your current and it's
figuring out what you need not just what
you want yeah so yeah I get that that
makes sense that the model works so it
scares the crap out of the ad tech guys
because they think they need that
control right but all it's doing is
making it so they can do their job a
hell of a lot easier so that all of
these things can happen a hell of a lot
easier right because then you focus on
what what is what does product
development what is what is setting up
an event what does anything right it's
not I went out and did a marketing thing
so I could get all the people to come
it's the it's that moment of creativity
in your head where you're like here's
this pain point here's this problem I'm
trying to solve and you either get it
right or you get it wrong right if you
market to a bunch of people then you
might give a bunch of people to come and
then you have to learn from that right
if you've got something out there that's
doing that marketing for you right and
it's going to take you
that picnic or that volleyball game they
don't need to own the marketing it's
[ __ ] better for them it's better for
everybody yes it does it does also
somewhat you know you never want that AI
recommendation engine to have you know
Walmart or Amazon or whatever sliding it
money etc so this is that's also kind of
like a who's making it is their codebase
transparent are they benevolent with
their ethics this is all super hearts
kind of reminds me of the neuro-link
kernel conversation yeah yeah but but
let's face it between you and me and a
decade something like this will manifest
so rather than sitting on your ass and
saying I hope that the person that makes
this has good ethics it's like how about
you train your ethics to be exceptional
and then go make it with other people
that have exceptional ethics right I
mean on the panel today they asked us
what our moral compass was the reality
is is that we all have that ownership
right and we're gonna put these checks
and balances in place so you know big
topic of the conference is about
compliance and regulation and things
like that it's like you know I know this
is a transition but it's like at the end
of the day you know we can't just pay
lip service to these things we have to
meet it on ourselves we have to carry
this forward right so and then and then
you you have to had this conversation
today about open sourcing intelligence
communities right the idea is is that
that will create lots of checks and
balances and and even if it's not quite
right you know the the level of like
open participation will create something
that's actually pretty good for most
people right there's this this little
gathering thing that happens every year
that I'm that I've never been to but
they get together and they on
Thanksgiving and they they basically
they stop doing all things electronic
and they just try to hang out and they
try to like kind of embrace nature and
and these are all like technicians and
and computer code you know coders and
basically people that I would go to work
with right and they set down their cell
phones and they
try to like kind of be people for a
little while right and and out of that
they've got it like they've got it the
whole thing only works because they all
bring that moral compass with them yeah
cuz it's easy to screw things up if you
don't bring your moral compass like you
can screw up your code you can screw up
your everything can be screwed up right
there's always a chance for corruption
and money is like the looming demon
because like we desperately need money
so we can pay our bills and so we can
get forward and and and there's this
perception that money gives you freedom
because then you don't have like this
just this this burden on your back right
I don't know how else to characterize it
but it's on all of us and and so you
know it's like but that very thing you
know that opportunity to make money it's
like you'll cut some corners you're like
I'm gonna make a trade here I'll do a
sacrifice right and that's where the
danger gets into something that's
powerful fascinating there was this sort
of moral compass that is getting trained
over time and then when there's a low on
the roller coaster in terms of money
then the moral compass might take a
backseat to money which this is so
interesting how are we talking about
money it's fascinating
everybody dreams of the same thing
they're like what will my life be with
no money right and so I'm envisioning
you know that we talked about the whacky
technology I'm envisioning a future
where we've got personal assistance that
we've paid for who basically helped us a
little life in the way that we want to
because a lot of us get stuck yeah we're
stuck because you know people are
telling us what to do or because you
know our parents told us what to do and
we're completely [ __ ] up right now and
it's just like so you know and that's
why you know coming all the way back to
the beginning it's like yeah I love the
computer science problems I love the
intellectual like the perfection of some
you know algorithmic you know data
modelling I love that but I also love
the fact that every now and then
this human element okay so we've been
going down so many different roads and
these have been super fascinating
individual experiences timeline of that
and AI recommendation solely just for
you all the way to the moral compass and
the money dilemma that's and how that's
going to change over time with AI and
automation and self-actualization just
changing so much over time so I want to
know these have been great roads is
there another road that we should cover
will before we come to a close that you
think would be interesting and I think
the only other thing that would be
really cool to talk about right now like
let's let's briefly touch on on kind of
like how I see music and the impact to
to my space because I think that's
really interesting so what I've what I
found over time is that the combination
everybody listens to music at work right
they're all doing their thing they're
listening you can see a different result
from people who are listening to music
but what's most interesting to me is
that the the the classic mentality is
you need to find team players look for
people who have done team sports what
for people who've done this right that's
the classic mentality what I found is
that people who want to reach out and
connect back to themselves through music
right tend to have the most unbelievable
cognitive abilities when it comes to
coding like they they produce not only
the most beautiful code but the most
effective and correct code it's it's an
astounding thing you can literally look
person after person after person and and
and we were talking earlier it might be
that there's different kinds of music
and I haven't studied it to that level
alright so first of all before we start
on the what kind of music can lead to
perfection and code which is likely
different for every person is it also
possible that listening to music while
working especially music that's maybe
very very heavy in lyrics that it just
takes cognitive it takes cognition away
from the task and that yeah and that
might take it'll take you longer to
complete the task more distractions
along the way it might be more
inspirational
what's really interesting about that is
that you know what I've observed is that
the different kinds of music or for
different activities and so effectively
you know it's funny the the the young
coders to come in and work for me you
don't they like they'll pretend like
they don't want to listen to classical
but when you find that right classical
piece they're like holy [ __ ] right and
then they and they're just like their
whole body just like pumps up and
they're just like coding machines I've
seen people that are on on different
basically in different states of mind
I'm trying to characterize that the
right way I'll skip that piece and I'll
just tell you the different state of
mind and and you can like in in the
level of being able to tune into that is
unreal yeah and so you're sitting there
there's this there's this running joke
about the Ballmer peak yeah okay you
know what the Ballmer peak is right it's
a running joke because basically the
idea is is that you need to get to the
point where your guard drops enough so
that you can tap into what you really
got and then all the sudden you'll start
producing like a maniac yes right and
that's what I'm binding is that like you
know I don't know what the right answer
is on the music side like I'm not I'm
not sufficiently deep and aware enough
to get that but I can see that some
things will cause people to like reach
that connectivity back to themselves and
then and then everybody is like so much
more capable than they think they are
like just just the amazing thing so they
can do so that was the last thing I want
to share I I'm loving this so to me it
kind it kind of reminds me a lot of not
only the word flow but also the word
channeling because there is something
that is source or all that is or god or
whatever that word is that is everything
and then our ability to tap into that
everything is just it's there but we
don't train it it's a muscle we have to
train it like questions our muscle words
your body to relax enough to let it
happen
yes
and so when we go through the process of
really deep meditation and relaxation
and getting into our body we are
dropping that guard sometimes it can be
done with the different substances as
well and it's so anti like the
fundamentals of what computer science
and coding and everything like like that
is to me and even in the industry but at
the same time like these coders realize
it they just don't know they realize it
like they get it yeah that's and you
unlocked it by playing classical music
which oh maybe one out of the ten was
like whoa why haven't I listened to
Beethoven since I was five and then the
next thing you know they have a
Beethoven playlist on Spotify right like
I played Phantom of the Opera music the
other day and everybody's like you know
they're like what is this they said some
choice words and then the moment arrives
we're like they're listening to it and
like the music and the emotions and
everything washes over them and you know
that's not like super effective coding
music but it's super energy yes this was
also interesting you mentioned that
different music for different flow
states and to get into so for example if
you and I are about to walk across of
coals that are heated like heated coals
like a like in the Tony and Tony Robbins
called a fire walk right and so if
you're about to do that you probably
don't want to listen to I don't know
some of the most chillest music you
probably want to listen to very pump up
music and then if you want to meditate
you probably don't listen to pump up
music if you want to be creative you
wanna listen that's whatever is creative
for you so I think music also triggers
different frequencies in the mind and
then that also triggers you to be like
we were saying just more effective in
that given task that you're trying treif
okay now we didn't touch on this though
if you play the wrong music at the wrong
time it can lead to severe distraction
like your efficacy your efficiency at
achieving the task is likely decreased
and and oddly what I notice is that
without some cultural suggestions or
PACS that at least the coders and
developers that I'm working with today
will often find their way towards that
you know very distracting very they're
not like mentally they don't boost them
right there and in in the way you it's
interesting though it's interesting the
way that you've described it because you
know where I'm kind of an infant in this
and I can just realize the the gut check
of like here's how to get my my team to
work very very effectively here's how to
get them to do better jobs here's how to
get more quality out of them right so
like I'll get everybody headphones and
then I'll get them a bunch of certain
kinds of music and then I'll do this and
that right and it's a tuning exercise
but I also realized that the reality is
is that these different pieces of music
just talking with you now it's like
they're unlocking a different type of
activity in there and their mind and
body almost like meditation yeah right
and then they come in and they're able
to do that really well like they might
be like they might be super cognitive
about whatever it is that's going on in
the music right it's just that they
can't code worth a damn it that this was
a really solid last exit on the on the
highway of our conversation it was so
good
Wow alright and here we are
to wrap up wow that was really profound
that was fascinating and I'm really
happy I'm really grateful we had you on
the show
it was super fun thank you yeah thanks
everyone for tuning in as you guys know
as we always close the show go and
create go build go manifest your destiny
into the world and much love thank you
so much during the conversation below in
the comments we'd love to hear your
thoughts about these things and also
join the public telegram the link is
below as well and so our wheels links so
do follow will as well
alright much love everyone peace
[Music]
how do you make the connection like what
is it like what do you look for when I
look at people um usually impact like I
look at the size of their node like how
strong their notice and interesting yeah
so now you do think about in a very like
qualitative assessment yeah 24/7 on
people yeah I was like there's never a
time that I turn it off well even the
guy that works at Taco Bell is building
but he doesn't think that way he's just
like I wake up and I just like go to
work do my thing
so I can pay my rent which is what a lot
of people are stuck in nowadays so how
do you pivot them away from now this
conversations so interesting
[Laughter]